(laughing)
(mumbling)
(upbeat jazz music)
- I have no idea what King
Cake is, but I assume it's
luxurious as fuck, because
its named after a king.
- I thought we were
eating king crab cakes.
I legit, I thought there was crab here.
- It's like a cake shaped like a baby.
- And each kid gets a piece, and the kid
that finds the king inside of it,
it's like they win.
- [Male] It's like a game.
(classical music playing)
- Fiddle dee dee, King
Cake, oh fuck (mumbles).
- Oh my God.
(classical music playing)
(mumbling)
- What is that?
Why is that there?
(classical music playing)
- What is that?
- It's giving birth.
- Oh my God, here she comes.
Oh my God.
- What is that?
- It's a boy.
- There's a naked toddler
who's trying to get a hug.
You know what?
- [Lady] The cake was
pregnant oh my God.
- Do I knight you?
- Is that how it goes with this?
- Does this make me the mother?
- I think so.
- Don't talk about me
eating near Jesus' crotch.
- Holy fuck, that's sugary.
- New Orleans people don't fuck around
because this is literally
icing and sugar on top.
- I'm just gonna say it.
- Oh I love it.
- This cake done a little heavy.
- It's like a sugar scrub
while you're eating it.
- It tastes like a
congealed Cinnabon sprinkled
with a pound and a half
of sugar in every bite.
- The whole experience of texture.
- And almost dying.
(laughter)
I don't know how we're
just getting past it.
- [Female] Great cake.
- Great cake.
- I do feel like we've experienced
a little bit of Mardi Gras.
- I think if I go to New
Orleans for Mardi Gras,
I'm going to be more excited
about the cake than the boobs.
- My first rule as King of this cake,
is that I get to eat the rest of
the cake, A, and I get pancakes.